[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on "Polycasts,"
I'm going to show you
a very important technique
for writing reusable elements.
Plus, I've got a boatload of
Polymer goodies to give away.
But you're going to
have to stick around
till the end of the
episode to figure out
how to get your hands on those.
So first thing's first.
Let's talk reusable components.
All right.
And what I'm going
to talk about today
is a very important
technique that applies
to both Polymer 0.8 and 0.5.
It's one of those things that
I see most beginners get wrong,
because frankly, it's
just really confusing.
So let me give you a scenario.
Let's say we have
a folder structure.
We're creating an
element that we
want to share with some folks.
And this is the look
of our project so far.
So we've got tiny-badge.html.
This is the tag that
we're going to create.
And then inside of here,
we've got our bower_components
directory.
And inside of there,
we've got polymer.html.
Now, if I open the definition
for tiny-badge.html,
you'll see up here at the top,
the first thing I'm doing is
I'm importing polymer.html.
And I'm importing it from that
bower_components directory.
So I'm basically hard-coding
the path bower_components
in my elements definition.
Let's say I'm happy with
the look of tiny-badge.
I want to share
it with the world.
So I publish it to
the Bower registry.
I tell everyone how cool
it is, and all my friends
go and install it.
Let's look at what their
project looks like, OK?
My buddy installed tiny-badge.
It ends up inside of his
bower_components directory.
So now they've got
polymer and tiny-badge
as siblings in their
bower_components directory.
But wait a sec.
If I open the definition
for tiny-badge.html,
you'll recall that I've got
this hard-coded bower_components
path in here.
So this element is
expecting a sibling,
bower_components directory.
It's expecting something to
exist right at this level.
But it doesn't, right?
We're inside of our friend's
bower_components structure,
because they installed
our components.
So this path right here is
going to give us a big, fat 404.
And our friend is going
to be super bummed out.
Now, we can change this.
We can totally fix this.
We can just change this
path to a relative path.
And we sometimes refer to this
as using the canonical path.
The idea here is that, if
you're using a front-end package
manager, all of your packages
are going to be siblings.
And so if you just use a
dot-dot-slash relative path,
you're basically
saying, hey, I'm
referring to something that
is in one of my sibling
directories.
So that's why we
call it canonical,
because you're always sort of
sibling to your dependencies.
But hold on a second.
Let's rewind a bit.
This is our original
project structure.
This is how we were
developing our component.
And the whole reason why
we had this hard-coded
bower_components
path was because we
needed to be able to
preview this thing while we
worked on it.
If we change this to
a canonical path here,
then we can't
preview our element.
So now we're in this
really crappy dilemma
of either being able to preview
our component as we're working
on it or being able
to actually share it
with people once it's finished.
And this is really not
a great dilemma to have.
So last year, we put
together an article
which explained a really clever
directory structure plus Bower
configuration hack you could
use to develop and preview
a sharable element.
What I'm about to
show you is a new tool
created by a member
of the Polymer team
which removes a lot
of this craziness
and lets you develop your
element in a very sane fashion.
So let's check that out.
So this is the element that
we're going to be creating.
Again, it's this sort
of tiny-badge element.
You could imagine it's
something you might toss inline
into a project, like a list
or something like that,
to let someone know
they've got some emails
or some alerts piling up.
And the first thing I'm going to
do is create a bower.json file.
I'm going to give
my element a name.
And I'm going to include
some dependencies.
So I'm asking for
webcomponentsjs and polymer.
Over in my terminal,
I'm going to run
bower install to pull down
all of those dependencies.
The next thing I'm
going to do is install
a library called polyserve.
So I'm using the npm command.
I'm doing a global install
to pull down polyserve.
And what polyserve
is is basically
a server that is going to let
you write your element using
canonical path URLs.
It then intercepts those
URLs, and it serves them
from your local
bower_components directory.
It was created by a
member of the Polymer team
to try and work around this
dilemma of not being able
to preview and share
the same component.
So I'm going to boot up
the polyserve server.
And you'll see here that
it started on port 8080,
and it's serving
tiny-badge from the path
localhost:8080/components/tiny
badge.
And over in my
project, I'm going
to create a
tiny-badge HTML file.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is import the
definition for Polymer.
And you'll note that I'm going
to use the canonical path when
I do this.
Then I'm going to
give my tiny-badge
a don-module with
an ID that matches
the name that I'm registering.
I'm going to throw a content
element inside of the template
there.
And lastly, I'm going to
call the Polymer constructor
and pass in the tiny-badge name.
I'm also going to
include a style tag.
And this is just to give my
tiny-badge a little bit of look
and feel.
You'll see that I'm
using that host selector
from the previous episodes.
So that way, I can target
the element itself.
Over in my demo HTML file, I'm
going to start off by including
a script tag for
webcomponents-lite.js.
And then I'm going
to include an HTML
import for my tiny-badge
element definition.
Lastly, I'm going to
include a style tag.
And I'm just going to use a
nicer font family on the page,
so the badge looks
a little nicer.
And then down in my body,
I'm going to create a list.
And inside this
list, I will drop
in a tiny-badge element
in line there so that we
can create a fake inbox.
Now, if I go over to Chrome
and preview everything,
you can see that I've got
the tiny-badge showing up.
If you look at the URL
that I'm using here,
it's
localhost:8080/components/tiny
badge/demo.html.
And the nice thing is that I'm
able to develop this component.
I'm able to preview it.
But I've written
its dependencies
using canonical path URLs.
So this component is also ready
to be published to the Bower
registry.
It's ready to be shared
with the whole world.
So there you have it.
Developing Polymer elements
just got way simpler.
Now, normally, this is
the part where I sign off,
and I tell you to
subscribe to the channel.
But today I've got a very
special announcement.
We've got a whole bunch of
just killer Polymer swag
that we want to give away to
a few of you lucky viewers.
So here is how this
is going to work.
You leave questions about
Polymer down in the comments.
And each time we shoot a new
episode, I'm going to go back,
pick some of the best
questions to answer on air.
And if your question gets
picked, you get some swag.
We got hoodies, stickers, toys,
laptop skins-- you name it.
If you want an autographed photo
of me with a corgi or a walrus,
we can do that.
So get your thinking caps on.
Drop me a line in the comments.
As always, thank you
so much for watching.
And I'll see you next time.
Hey, Polycasters.
It's Rob here, letting
you know I've got a brand
new show called "LazyWeb."
It's all the highlights
from last week's news
on the web bundled up for
your viewing pleasure.
You can follow this link
over here to check it out.
Be sure to subscribe.
Let us know what you
think on the Twitters.
And as always,
thanks for watching.